these fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on I say here open a
eyes Jim was a selection of gaming
environments for reinforcement learning
algorithms this is a class of techniques
that are able to learn and perform an
optimal chain of actions in an
environment this environment could be
playing video games navigating your
drone around or teaching digital
creatures to walk in this system people
could create new reinforcement learning
programs and decide who's a I is the
best Jim was a ton of fun but have a
look at this one how is this different
from Jim this new software platform
universe works not only for
reinforcement learning algorithms but
for arbitrary programs like a freestyle
wrestling competition for AI researchers
the list of games include GTA 5 Mirror's
Edge Starcraft 2 civilization 5
minecraft portal and a lot more this
time around super exciting you can
download this framework right now and
proceed testing one can also perform
different browser tasks such as booking
a plane ticket or other endeavors that
require navigating around in a web
browser interface given the current
software architecture for universe
practically any task where automation
makes self can be included in the future
and we don't need to make any intrusive
changes to the game itself in fact we
don't even have to have access to the
source code this is huge especially
given that many of these games are
proprietary software so to make this
happen
individual deals had taken place between
the game development companies and open
AI when the company was founded by Elon
Musk and some of them they have picked
up so many of the most talented AI
researchers around the globe and I am so
happy to see that it really really shows
there is an excellent blog post
describing the details of the system
make sure to have a look also I reckon
that our comment section is the absolute
best I've seen on YouTube feel free to
participate or start a discussion there
are always plenty of amazing ideas in
the comment section thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time
[Music]